so out of all the Star Wars prequels
that came out this was the one that felt
the closest like a Star Wars movie it
opens with star destroyers and a space
battle and lightsabers and going in and
rescuing people and running through the
ship and shooting lasers and yeah this
is Star Wars and it's easy to follow
once again the focus is on the
simplicity of the character you
understand why Anakin is angry you
understand what he's going through now
does that make up for everything
no it's still by definition a pretty bad
movie but this is the first time
watching or I said you know what I'm
glad I saw a Star Wars brief there's
just enough good things and inside and
visuals that maybe glad that I paid the
money to go see it it's a few years
later and Anakin finds out that Amidala
is pregnant this is already big trouble
that's gonna be even bigger trouble when
he has a vision showing that she's
probably gonna die a child but he's
becoming more chummy chummy with
Palpatine as he tells him that the ways
of the dark side can actually find a way
to save her life
slowly but surely Anakin is being won
over to that side as I'll be one goes to
do more of that political sword fighting
nonsense that's in the other films but
it's not as focused on here the focus is
what it should be on Anakin and I think
most people know what's gonna happen
he's gonna become Darth Vader things are
gonna go wrong there's gonna be a big
separation between him and obi-wan but
this is the first time it plays out
closer to how you may think it's
supposed to play out
there's betrayal there's manipulation
there's big sword fights there's
explosions there's student against
teacher the ultimate failure and yet
there's still so many other dumb scenes
like when Anakin does turn as everybody
says it's way too fast and out of
nowhere it's one thing to say you all
learn the dark side to save your loved
one but to kill so many people to
completely switch sides and kill young
ones or younglings or whatever hell
they're called it's completely out of
nowhere and the acting is not strong it
but out of all of them this is probably
the most visual story tale you can watch
this on mute on al I almost recommend it
and still get an idea of what's going on
it felt more like we're in the Star Wars
universe like it has a history the scene
at the Opera where he's giving the
backstory in the mythos that's one of
the best moments I've seen in any Star
Wars movie and everybody whether they're
doing a good job acting or not look the
part Anakin looks amazing this is what
you would imagine a young angry Darth
Vader would look like but yes like I
said before I make fun of the moments
you make fun of to Darth Vader shouting
no the stupid romantic dialogue to feel
so forced the plot threads that don't
add up I make fun of it all too but at
the very least I finally got something
that felt a little closer to what these
prequels was supposed to be it is dark
it is brooding it is gritty it has big
battles and manipulation that you can
actually follow this time truth be told
it's a movie
I don't mind popping in every once in a
while do I laugh at the stupid scene
sure and do I still point out all the
things that don't make sense yeah but
the fight scenes and the cinematography
and the way it visually tells it's
touring is really really interesting by
no means perfect I don't even really
think you can say it's good but it has
good things in it some of them the best
out of any of the Star Wars movies and
it's hard for me not to recommend that
the first ones interesting to watch to
see just how bad it can be but you don't
really need to see it in order to figure
out what's going on here and the second
one is a complete forgettable mess this
is the first one where I felt like I
actually learned a little something or
at least what the intention was I didn't
feel the emotions but I felt the idea
behind the emotions if that makes sense
it's a tough call if you want to see the
movie to know a little bit more about
what was supposed to be going on it's
interesting but if you want an actual
good movie I still can't say that it is
but at least it was finally feeling like
Star
we're then looking like star wars Eve if
we had to put up with a lot of dumb
bullshit I think you can figure out if
this is something you would benefit from
or if it would just piss you off more
and for a while it seemed like this was
the end of the Star Wars movies but
literally and figuratively a new hope
seemed to be in the future